the uk wants to be a global leader on
net zero as we've been saying well that
is by 2050. london's mayor however sadiq
khan wants his city to be net zero by
2030. now that is ambitious but with
more than half of the world living in
urban areas cities and the people in
them will need to play a crucial role in
the green transition and mohammed i'm
interested to bring you in on this
you're talking to us from nairobi it's a
city which has seen rapid urbanization
there's a lot of work isn't there for
your city to
to commit to its green
potential
yeah
i think we in the in the developing
world i think what we're seeing is
cities growing rapidly and i think it's
important that they grow but they grow
in a low carbon way and and we need to
do everything to help our cities become
greener rather than ending up to be big
pollutant metropolis i think
that will need to be re-engineered you
know later and so i think it's important
for us to get this message through that
the way we've approached cities we need
to change our mindset about them we need
to change the design of our cities i
think people living and working together
can help to these emissions and so what
we need to do this time is create cities
with a mixture of homes and shops and
workplaces that are close to our
commuting
and shopping trips so that we can have
them shorter and we can actually be able
to get to places by walking by cycling
and having an effective public transport
i think if we we design cities and and
do that in a way that we can actually
help
make the most out of the little space
that we have we now see in particularly
in nairobi and this is true for a lot of
the developing country cities a lot of
migration to the major cities and so
space is cast and so what we need is
modern blocks of flux that are efficient
use of space that can also be quite
energy efficient and if we build these
with the right materials with proper
insulation i think we can get our cities
greener and and help them contribute to
the global efforts to tackle climate
i just want to bring you in here talking
about sadiq khan he thinks he can go net
zero by 2030 is that just a gimmick or
can he do it
it's tall ask but cities are absolutely
crucial they're about 70 of global
emissions and if you think about cities
like london we tend to build on
coastlines and around big rivers
and that's a big problem when we have
sea level rise and flooding so building
resilience in cities is just as
important as net zero and it can't be
overlooked when we're talking about
cities and climate change
you